let's go next to our caller from the
three four seven area code who's calling
today from three four seven oh yes it is
who's this this is Alex from Brooklyn
New York
hey Alex what's up so I had two things
on my mind one is sort of my opinion one
I wanted to ask for yours and they're
both an opinion they're both related to
impeachment rather than Iran sure so the
first thing I wanted to talk about was
this like idea from Democrats sort of
like this you know examination of this
impeachment that you know as this thing
will progress and maybe afterwards no
Americans will kind of look back on this
and think oh my goodness how could we
support Trump like what is going on like
we fell to this ideology and the sort of
fear-mongering that led us to vote for
Trump when in reality in my opinion
we're going to have something more of
the lines of how people look at the
civil war in a sense of that there are
still a population in this country that
still things that the civil war was you
know northern aggression or it's about
you know disruption of state rights and
whatnot that's interesting so if I
understand correctly what you're saying
is no matter what happens during the
Trump administration with Iran or with
anything else eventually there will be
people who will see Trump as this great
hero much like you still have people who
see the civil war as being about states
rights rather than about slavery or
whatever like there will always be a
contingent that sees it that way
yes when I see like kids at Trump
rallies you know cheering them on
I feel like many years from now they'll
tell their kids Trump was the greatest
president ever whether it's you know
ends in ten months or four
half years but I don't know long I think
maybe you're overstating the importance
that Trump is going to have historically
I mean I hope so I hope that
historically Trump will be seen as an
aberration but that people won't talk
about him that much one way or the other
much the same way that a lot of
presidents aren't really discussed very
much today but the more erratic his
behavior of course the more likely that
that he does remain a topic of
conversation but it's an interesting
point of view for sure the idea that
there's always going to be at the same
time though you know if you think back
to like William Howard Taft is there a
contingent that goes around idolizing
Taft today he just kind of become not
not not a big factor maybe Trump would
be the same although certainly he would
ideally be seen as an aberration no
matter how long it goes I hope as well
yeah and the second point that I want to
bring up actually does relate to the
impeachment trials but it also has
something to do with Iran so I was
watching one of your videos about Tucker
Carlson talking about how you know we
shouldn't be in this war with Iran like
so on and so forth and he mentioned John
Bolton as a non genius and you know to a
certain point I agree with him on that
yeah but in his commentary he sort of
you know dismisses John Bolton and I was
wondering if you think he might be
playing this sort of like side role of
dismissing John Bolton because in the
case that he does somehow end up
testifying in the Senate although it's
unlikely we can play off as you know all
this guy he's a war monger and you know
even though he I don't believe he had
anything to he had anything to do with
Iran he on the other hand could be
dismissed as just another war monger and
his testimony is worth little to nothing
I don't think that that's Tucker's
motivation if anything it's just that
Tucker has always had disagreements with
John Bolton because John volt Bolton is
very interventionist and Tucker Carlson
has an anti interventionist streak I
don't think it's nearly as calculated as
you're suggesting Alex thank you so much
great to hear from you I do have to move
on to other callers and I hope to hear
from you again